uh let's see here let's go to our caller
from the 731 area code who's calling
today from 731
hey david is that me yes it is who's
this
this is david from jackson tennessee
love it what's going
on uh so i was watching
a clip from the same cg show the other
day
and he made a comment that i took slight
issue with and i was wondering if i
could get your opinion on it
sure i mean i'm gonna have to take your
word that you're you're quoting it
accurately but go ahead
uh basically he was talking about
some right-wing commentator i can't
remember the name of and he said
when it comes to right-wing commentators
it's essentially
you sometimes need to ask the question
is this person
evil or stupid or most of the time
basically that i agree with you
and well i don't know
i can understand where he's coming from
because i look at a guy like
michael knowles for example i think he
can intentionally
misrepresent certain things and i could
see why he would see
someone like that as evil or you can
look at
like matt walsh also in the daily wire
and i could see why you'd think he's
maybe less than intelligent
but i honestly think ben shapiro i think
he's
very intelligent and i think that he
you know i don't think that he's
actually trying to misdirect his
audience
i think he believes that conservative
economics is the way to go
and i think it's kind of unfair to
refer to someone like him as evil well
so maybe stupid is a pejorative but if
he
really believes conservative right-wing
economics
is the way to go and we know
that it's not from having you know 120
150 180 years
of evidence to suggest that it we don't
have to say that he's stupid but we
could say he's wrong on the facts right
like if we were able to say
shapiro's factually wrong that tax cuts
for the rich stimulate the economy
he doesn't have to be evil and stupid is
a bit of an ad hominem but we could say
he's just wrong
right could we call it ignorance
yeah i would say that's fine okay so i
think maybe stupid is too pejorative
but what we're talking about is
ignorance to the facts and i think in
that sense it's sort of getting to
what's going on
yeah it just it bothered me a little bit
just because like i said i'm from
tennessee
yeah and even though i'm a progressive
i've
tons of friends and family who are
conservative and
my dad is probably the smartest person i
personally know and he's
a massive ronald reagan fan and all that
but then
it baffles me that he's so intelligent
and he still believes it but
i think my dad's a great guy and he's
very smart so well he
he may he very well may be but is it
possible that because of your dad's
ideology
he may be selectively ignoring certain
facts in order to
keep his ideology neat and tidy
yeah wouldn't make him a bad person
yeah i think i see what you're saying
but
honestly i think everybody does that a
little bit i guess you could say
conservatives do that more
but i think that's just human nature it
is no there's no denying that
that i agree with yeah
but anyway that was just i was wondering
what you thought about that i wasn't a
big fan of that comment but
i could see where he was coming from and
i don't know it sounds like you don't
like the tone but you mostly agree with
the substance
yeah i guess so yeah all right my friend
thank you for the call i appreciate it
david in tennessee
wow a lot happening on the phone lines
today